- What about free will?
- Free will is also a nice exercise.
Free will is an illusion that we,
A.I. people are gonna solve.
- (Interviewer) So, what do you think,
once we solve it, that
solution will look like?
Once we've put it in the page?
- (Guest) It's going to look like...
First of all, it will look like a machine.
A machine that acts as though
it has free will.
It communicates with
other machines as though
they have free will,
and you wouldn't be able
to tell the difference
between a machine that does
and a machine that doesn't
have free will.
- (Interviewer) So, the
illusion, it propagates
the illusion of free will amongst
the other machines?
- (Guest) And faking it is having it.
Okay?
That's what true
intelligence is all about.
Faking intelligence is intelligence,
because it's not easy to fake.
It's very hard to fake, and you can only
fake if you have it.
- (laughs)
That's such a beautiful statement.
(laughs)
You can't fake it, if you don't have it.